what is up fellow squad fans it is I
your leader coming at you with an update
I should have written a script for this
video I just felt like it's been a while
since we've talked face-to-face a
sincere down-to-earth honest discussion
which is why I'm talking normally this
is my normal voice this is how I greet
and talk to everyone I really just
wanted to say thank you things have been
going well lately I am I'm really
enjoying seeing the outcome of how you
guys enjoy the videos reading all the
comments loving all the support on the
South Park series it really brings me
back to have a let's play on the series
finally I've said it before but I really
just wait for games that I know that you
guys are gonna like and that I'm gonna
like and it takes time obviously a lot
of times but once they hit it really
feels like a special thing so I really
appreciate that you guys join the daily
journey of those it's a lot of fun so I
just wanted to say thank you I'm so glad
I missed the whole like off come on we
need another one seeing that kind of
thing in the comments it's always fun
you know that's really how I fell in
love with YouTube was because I watched
Let's Plays I watched daily Let's Plays
really terrible Let's Plays but still
just the concept of everyday you know
you have a series to watch was such a
fun thing and I loved the fact that I
can bring that to my audience again you
know despite all this time I do make
daily videos as normal nothing has
really changed there but I feel like I
finally figured out this new formula
when I change to this office my style of
videos completely you know some of it
may have been lost but some of it was
gained as well and I love the weekly
videos that I do with a fan interaction
PewDiePie submission a lot reddit
[ __ ] and your life you lose and me
just ranting about stuff I finally feel
like I figured it out you know I figured
out a series of videos that I can keep
up and that feels fresh and that's fun
to me to record I can do all these
things in a way that I
have to get gray hair ironically my hair
is white so I don't you get the point
another thing that I'm super grateful
for is that you guys are buying my March
March for me is always like yeah okay
yeah I make money out of it obviously
but I'm so happy that guys are just you
guys are just interested it's the stuff
that I put out it's a it's a very
humbling thing that someone chooses to
support you
you know publicly by wearing something
that represents me I think I think that
makes me really really proud and I think
probably for the first time pre to PI as
a brand that you probably would at least
wear in public without getting punched
in the face part of the proceeds from
the represent shirts goes to save the
children as well and so far we've got a
twenty thousand dollars and this in the
name of squad fam and that's a great
thing I really appreciate that we also
have the meatball March which of course
is the greatest March ever because I
designed that merch my god can we get a
picture look at that name
Swedish ten out of ten perfection he's
like a good spaghetti meatball accepted
Swedish meatball we also have the chair
which I designed myself it's kind of
expensive for a chair but for what you
get with it my god this chair has
changed my life okay also if you get one
now you get the meatball shirt how about
that now it sounds like I'm just trying
to sell you a bunch of stuff don't maybe
a little bit I'm gonna be honest maybe a
little bit but mainly I want to say
namaste which means apparently nice to
meet you but I mean it in the context of
thank you
tuck stomach get they would all smell it
all day yeah three shut the lid are you
other than that I'm looking forward to
keep doing more videos which it feels
like a great thing to say sometimes the
whole process of making videos can come
and go in waves sometimes you're not bad
into it maybe you're having a bad day
you don't feel creative and you're like
I don't know what to do but regardless I
appreciate you guys it means a lot I
love you I'm gonna end it here and I
think that's a good time to end it and
just remember never grill without a nice
fro 57 million subscribers really ok
thanks for leaving like squad fam patio
and brofist